and like we show up in like chicks dudes
everybody wants to suck our [ __ ] dick
that is not true not a single 100 True
really that never happened well you
didn't go to nerd Kingdom my friend nerd
Kingdom which is Pinball Hall of Fame
everybody wanted to [ __ ] one of our
dicks and balls in their mouth right
[Music]
I'm excited to talk about something uh
that I know you're really passionate
about okay diarrhea you're one of many
even better okay what do you think about
um in 2024
DeLorean releasing yes another iteration
of their famous car well the next uh
well it's not even an iteration of the
car it's a new model right it's like not
even the same company they've been
talking about this for five years bro
are they actually doing it now I know
they've been talking about it every year
forever yeah is it the same people it is
so actually Cameron who runs DeLorean
now is a good friend of ours he stopped
by last week to just like run us through
the entire project it's called an alpha
five they have been talking about this
for many years the company DeLorean is
now owned by the win family
um Cameron's dad got the trademark very
win as in like Steve win Steve win is
not the same win that you're thinking
like a British auto body shop owner
essentially that was working on All The
Deloreans and then he knew that the Mark
was up and he took it and they've been
running it for like the last couple
decades right and so they had their
Factory down in Texas and they have all
the refurbished parts and they've just
been working on the existing DMC 12s
there's like eight there were initially
like eight or nine thousand producers
probably only like a thousand of them
are actually on the streets right so
they're like working on those cars for
the last couple decades and now they
have this new model called the alpha 5
that they're finally announcing it's
electric
um are they releasing it are they going
to release it through one of the the
bigger like companies no they're
releasing it's their car yeah and it's
got the golden door still yeah [ __ ] yeah
yeah
I've learned a lot about how this works
and it's it kind of makes me think that
eventually everyone will be almost
designing and making their own cars
because of the way that these electric
cars work it's almost like the chassis
or like this it's called the skateboard
right like the bottom part of it they're
it's like when we Design shoes it's the
same thing shoes a lot of them use the
same molds especially if they're a volk
sole like a Vans and so you see that's
why everyone's been doing their own
shoes over the last 10 years where every
brand has their own sneaker now because
if you have the bottom part you can
build the upper and just make it look a
little different now it's your sneaker
and I think the same is happening with
cars where you just have
boilerplate stock skateboards that
people are going to build different
uppers on and so this is one really good
example of that also they're not even
making a DeLorean Factory this time for
this car right there's like putting it
be made at a different yeah there's like
a whole different Factory that's working
on these but I think it's cool there's
like a whole nft play that goes along
with it that we've kind of been uh
talking to them about on how to on how
do yeah and that'll get you on the sign
up list because they just want to make
sure that people are like really
invested in buying these things so like
it's there's like a little club that
you're in if you if you have the
internet yeah they haven't cemented any
of the details of it yet yet so like
don't take my word for it but I know
that they're thinking about doing this
nft play where if you Mint one of their
nfts and you can get onto the list and
then
um you know Teslas were already working
like that right you have like a wait
list and you could sell your spot on
eBay and so they're like instead of
letting them do that in like a
centralized way on eBay like why don't
we do it so that uh it's done through
the blockchain and then everyone can you
know be a part of it and DeLorean can
also have a little bit of ownership in
that as well is it gonna have a flux
capacitor like in the middle I don't
think they're playing to any of the back
of the Future car version because I feel
like all the time buyers are all Back to
the Future this is a really good it is
true I think many of the DeLorean fans
are Back to the Future
that's that's the joke in American Dad
where he has a DeLorean and he's never
seen Back to the Future and people will
constantly ask him and he's like what is
this what are you talking about
he's like
[Laughter]
a crazy thing is I used to see your car
all the time back in the day yeah
because I added DeLorean too in 2009 and
for 10 years and I used to go to the
same shop over with Danny botkin yeah
okay so you know yeah and I used to your
car used to it was there sometimes it
was a lot which is why eventually had to
sell it because I was just like that's
everyone's story bro with a DeLorean
right yeah so I understand the the
tribulations of owning one and how yeah
plus it is true it's like I was a huge
fan of Back to the Future and everywhere
you went wouldn't people always be like
I mean if they especially if they know
it's your card yeah they're gonna take
pictures with it yeah but did you ever
um feel like it was being harassed like
even just parking it somewhere yeah and
it would be sketchy driving that car
because there's always some 40 year old
white guy that was like almost running
into you because he was trying to take a
photo oh my God and so you're just like
please like it's okay but just like hold
on you know and so you're on a freeway
and you just see someone like and
they're like hey hey and I'm just like
hi you know whatever you know it's true
as I get closer to 40 I can't drive and
take photos at the same time
it's like if my eyes look in that
direction my car is gonna just run right
into the center divider yeah always so
that yeah okay you be honest you
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] okay you guys
well your brother has one too doesn't he
no my buddy Chad does but did you did
you guys did you guys play The Back to
the Future theme song while you're
driving that phone oh the first time I
got it a hundred percent I am um I'm I'm
outing myself as a total nerd because I
really did start liking the car more for
John DeLorean story in the design yeah
yeah it is it is you start getting
really deep into the weeds of what
DeLorean what was it back to the future
that got you to buy it and then you got
more into the history I've watched that
movie growing up and it was my favorite
film yeah and I said if I am ever
successful enough to own one of these
I'm gonna do it and so when I turned 30
for my 30th birthday went out and I got
the world's best DeLorean it only had
600 400 miles on it when I bought it it
sat in the museum for 30 years holy [ __ ]
then but even that breaks down
even more than it was if you don't use
it it's sad yeah yeah it was like a
refrigerator that had just been sitting
there for so my buddy Chad you guys know
Chad um we went to the Pinball Hall of
Fame in Vegas I love that spot [ __ ]
tight right so we show up in the and we
take his DeLorean right and like we show
up in like chicks dudes everybody wants
to suck our [ __ ] dick that is not
true not a single 100 True really that
never happened well you didn't go to
nerd Kingdom my friend nerd Kingdom
which is Pinball Hall of Fame everybody
wanted to [ __ ] one of our dicks and
balls in their mouth so everybody dude
so we pull up we the golf the doors come
up and [ __ ] right and we go in there
we're playing pinball we're the [ __ ]
[ __ ] everyone's high-fiving us everyone
loves us
it's too far for you then we're on our
way out right and we parked out front of
course and on our way out we get in the
car and all this [ __ ] and everyone's
everyone's watching all right see you
guys in the future and [ __ ] yeah where
you're going where you're
here and then it's like
dude it happened so many times this is
on Valentine's Day so then everybody all
these like nerds were salivating about
the car they all got to come up and
touch the car because we're trying to
we're trying to push start it yes so
we're pushed starting a chat sitting in
the front he's like working the ignition
we're push starting
love it they're not just pushing it
they're like like
they're kissing it it's like an
experience for them you know they get to
get that close to it so then our it was
Valentine's Day our our chicks had to
come pick our wives would come pick us
up to go to Valentine's Day dinner
yeah well we left the car in a tow truck
coolest dudes the coolest dudes to the
biggest [ __ ] movies
that sounds like a Will Ferrell buddy
movie or something yeah yeah it's crazy
but I don't think I'm not a single woman
ever said anything to me about that car
I drove it home I remember the first day
my wife looked at it and she was like it
looks like a microwave yeah like
everyone said like you got chicks in
that thing I'm like no it's like all
dads yeah all the other guys all the
younger people all the time had no
reference points they were like what
like kids would pull up next to me
they're like what kind of car is that
I'm just like like needles like laughing
you get the back of the future villains
yeah and I was just like it's a warning
okay you'll never understand is it's
like it's not a cool younger if you take
it to Melrose like people think it's a
foreign
[Laughter]
that's before like retro kind of got way
cool yeah so people weren't even
interested exactly that it was this
weird time yeah caveat renfair chicks
it's good they like that they like the
DeLorean well yeah because it's Canon it
could go back in time
I wasn't hanging out where the ren Fair
ranfair chicks are [ __ ] interesting
bro the absolutely I believe uh because
you'll get a bunch of like everyday
driving you'll just get a bunch of
Lights like you'll hear the same things
the only thing that I ever heard that I
actually thought was really funny
because uh I was living in Downey at the
time so I was like stopped at some gas
station in Pico Rivera it's all cholos
and this one like uh cholo guy came up
and he goes hey can I borrow your car I
was like what for why you want to go
back in time he goes hey I just want to
pay my phone bill
this is the most normal [ __ ] and then he
walked away and I was like that's
actually the most like creative
refreshing he's like sir do you think it
would get me to Metro PCS
sorry I just want to pay my phone bill
on time he was like the future that
guy's crazy for a very long time yeah
but yeah you hear all the same stuff and
you the thing is like if I would park it
on Melrose I would always come back out
to uh people sitting on it taking photos
yeah there's a familiarity people have
with the door because they think they
know it yeah sometimes like in
celebrities yeah yeah they're too comfy
yeah yeah but they they're not gonna do
that so did you end up selling it
because it kept breaking down a lot uh
no well it wasn't breaking finally got
it to the point where it wasn't I never
got 11 years yeah and uh and I just sunk
tons of money in it and uh by that point
I just sold it because it was like I had
a buyer that actually bit at that price
yeah so then I was like all right cool
it got sent to Denmark and now it's just
it's the only DeLorean in its town which
I lost that's cool yeah yeah that's cool
it sounds like the history of the like
owning a DeLorean is very similar to
owning a Miata
they sold it
earlier yeah people have a really strong
relationship with that car people love
that people come up same guys [ __ ]
yeah trying to drive 40 year old white
dudes you get [ __ ] with that and I'm
like totally
that's what I can't wait for because I'm
gonna get a Keaton Batmobile one day and
when I pull up at home I honestly think
I'm worried about Nikki's Vision because
her eyes
so far back like they'll freeze in the
back of her [ __ ] head
[Music]
[Music]